well it's actually about real-time
decision-making right so which so and
what I'm gonna do I think is going
faster over some of the material and
sort of get to the end and not to
mention or a bit over on time so I'll
I'll try to save us some and what I want
to do is talk about real-time
decision-making and especially what
optimization has what the implications
of fast optimization are for real-time
decision-making right so and they I mean
in the canonical application I'm
thinking of is control although it's a
lot of other things as well
so okay and I think I'll go fast because
I think people have seen some of these
things and but I'll go fast so I'll
start with with convex optimization just
a quick I'm gonna go very fast over a
whirlwind overview of sort of what it is
and all that sort of stuff to sort of
get to the real part which is the
real-time stuff okay so that's a visit
convex optimization problem you have to
choose a variable X there's an objective
inequality constraints equality
constraints the Equality constraints are
linear and the objective and inequality
constraints are convex so they they
curve up right so that's a convex
optimization problem what is emerged is
sort of the canonical form or I should
say actually the intermediate form as
you would say in like a computer you
know as a as a compiler or something
like that the intermediate form what has
emerged is something like this you
minimize a linear function subject to
equality constraints and the constraint
that the variable X is in a cone now if
this is that X is element Y is
non-negative this is a linear program
and by suite swapping out the cone you
get different other problems and this is
essentially the intermediate form now
for convex optimization and literally I
mean that because well there are systems
that compile something written in a
high-level language into this
intermediate form and then there's a
whole bunch of people working on
actually solvers for this intermediate
form okay so why well I mean it's it's
this is beautiful mathematics and stuff
like that we can start with that
getting nothing more interesting is that
you can actually solve them so I mean
that's actually the the interesting part
it unifies a lot of things so you'd have
you'd have different problems from you
know very different area
and it turns out they're very closely
related and this is not obvious I mean
this would be things like you know stuff
from information theory and circuit
design right I mean these are like
wildly different fields in fact the
people in them don't really like each
other and are horrified to find out how
close some of the mathematics they work
on is related right so they're very
uncomfortable both ways by the way so
and this is tons of applications so and
a lot more than previously thought so I
you know I won't go I won't say a lot
about this but you know there's a bunch
of machine learning and statistics
finance supply chain all sorts of stuff
control is one that's one of the things
I'll be talking about networking so
designing operating and network all
sorts of other stuff I think I'll go
fast to get to the point so the state of
the art right now is something like this
yeah if you have thousands to ten
thousands of variables constraints you
can solve these by methods that have
been around for maybe twenty years now
right and they're getting better and
there's still places where they're not
you know they're not completely reliable
it's it's moving its going to happen so
this is not quite a technology but it's
you know it's getting there um one other
thing that has emerged in the last 5-10
years is basically high-level language
support domain-specific languages for
convex optimization okay I mean the
optimization in general but I'm talking
about convex here and the ideas you
described a problem in a high level
language that is automatically compiled
into one of these intermediate forms
which is a cone program and then that
cone program is solved by a standard
solver right so and I mean there's
there's a lot more to this but at the
highest level this is what it is it's
it's fairly straight straightforward now
what this does is it allows you to do
rapid prototyping for small and medium
problems and actually it's radically
changed teaching right because it means
what you can do is instead of it being a
pain in the ass to actually solve a
convex problem it's actually writing a
five line script and so it means that if
you're teaching it doesn't matter where
which department the students are from
they're gonna do whether they like it or
not signal processing vision networking
circuit design finance you know control
etc right period and it's easy it's like
five you know you're right it's a short
thing okay one of these there's several
by now this is this is the one that's
most widely
used I guess it's in MATLAB
unfortunately there's ones now in actual
languages in things like Python and and
Julia but the idea would be something
like this you know here would be your
mathematical description of what you
want to do this is a support vector
machine classifier and the idea is to
have the source code look as close to
the mathematics as possible right so
that's it then if you read just a little
tiny bit of MATLAB syntax
this will make total sense to you so
this would be this is the idea so the
idea is you'd write this this thing
would be then compiled into a cone
program that cone program would be
solved and then you'd solve this now of
course for a support vector machine this
would be idiotic because there are in
fact extremely web because so many
people use smart vector machines there
are there would be all sorts of
unbelievably optimized codes for doing
this and this would run you know it's
something like 1/100 the speed actually
our goal is 1/10 so the goal is to have
is to be 1/10 as fast as the custom
method right so people sometimes say to
me I'm sorry didn't you mean you want to
be 10x faster and I'd say no no we want
to be 10x slower people like I don't get
it we say yeah because our coding time
will be 10 to the 5 times faster right
so that's the idea so oh I should say
the other reason the other reason is
suppose you came along and decided that
you wanted the first 10 waits to be
positive actually there'd be perfectly
good cases where that might be and you
would simply add that as a constraint
here and it would it would run right so
ok ah so now we get to what the main
point is which is real-time embedded
optimization so and what I'll do is sort
of just talk about some of the ideas
right so it turns out that in a lot of
cases these are online applications you
solve the same problem but with
different data so the data changes right
obvious ones would be well control right
so in control you're effectively or an
estimation you're estimating something
or making good actions but things change
right you like it's another tenth of a
second and you get another you know nav
update or something like this in the new
you get
you get you know Sauron or actually the
goals have changed in finance would be
the same same thing you you solve a new
problem because you have new estimates
of you know returns risks all sorts of
other stuff this kind of things now of
course this is actually used now it's
been used for decades in areas like
supply chain right so I mean this is
just completely so people do and the
reason is that the time scales are
longer and so you can solve a big you
can solve a big problem and it's been
used in in a bunch of areas there it's
gonna say what else has to say about
that in fact I'll I'll come back and say
something about about these two things
in a bit so what's not obvious is this
is it turns out you can actually solve
these problems in I mean the convex
problems in milliseconds or microseconds
these are modest and small sized things
and just turns out you can do this it's
not even that fancy or hard to do this
actually and actually this is what the
talk is about this changes everything so
and I can take his I mean I'm in I was
in control and I mean just to make a
caricature of it the story would go
something like this there would be there
would be I would be in control David
would be no our let's say I mean and
then someone would come along and say
what do you do I'm sort of pretending
you're nowhere if you don't mind so and
I would say and you'd say well you know
we do supply chain stuff and we estimate
how many people going to order this and
the capacity of this and blah blah blah
we have 25,000 variables and we then we
solve this big linear program and we
decide how much stuff just ship from
where to where right that that's my
summary of our right it's pretty stuff
it's you know it's pretty sophisticated
right and then they turn the B and they
say what do you do in control and I go
well it's kind of the same thing I get
updates of course I get them a hundred
times a second and then I have to make a
decision 100 times a second and they go
well what do you do do you do all the
sophisticated things David does and I'd
say no no because we have to do it every
10 milliseconds right what do you do and
the honest truth is this we multiply by
a matrix that's true so you get on an
airplane anything start an engine that's
what's happening not much more hey you
have a Kalman filter maybe you multiply
by two matrices or something but
basically we're talking like you know
level two right barely I mean we're
talking to matrix vector multiplies
right that's actually what happens right
because you know if you have a control
system on an airplane you got 12
measurements come in and you have to
make eight choices but you have to do it
ten times or a hundred times a second
okay so then I would say that explains
why I can't solve a giant LP like David
Wright which is the sophisticated thing
taking into account warehouse capacities
shipping capacities all sorts you know
piecewise linear costs beautiful
sophisticated stuff right and I'd say
well I can't do that because I have to
do this 100 times a second oh and I have
to do it without fail everybody got this
right so okay that was the picture I
told myself if someone said well why
don't you in control do these fancy
things that these people over here know
are doing and I would say we can't
because this is too hard right
anyway that's all false it's all wrong
we can solve Q peas in milliseconds or
microseconds right by the way pretty
much no one knows this or they're
ignoring it or I don't know or they're
whatever but it's true right and
actually it's quite interesting because
it's not at all clear like I mean people
aren't thinking about this but some are
actually more than something okay I'll
just give it this is I I don't need to
give an example but it I mean a quick
example we're just just to show you what
an embedded thing might look like is you
would need to move you're gonna push
something from one place to another by
applying a force you're gonna you're
gonna do this you're gonna push on it
hard enough and then the limit here is
one you're gonna push on it hard enough
that by the time it arrives at its
destination it's gonna be shaking if you
just push it because you're gonna excite
internal vibration modes right so it's a
convex problem and you can just solve
that right and you would get something
like that that's the optimal force you
should apply right and you can go back
you can go back and interpret it after
the fact but after a while it's better
just to say screw it that's just the
solution and it came from convex
optimization I mean that's that that's
that's the right way to think I mean you
could interpret and of course you have
to push it to the left if you're gonna
move it or push it to the right of
course you have to push it and then
someone would say what's that you'd say
oh that's active I'm actively removing
the energy I have inserted into the
vibration modes right but I mean it's
better off just saying that's the
solution
right so okay
okay so what do you need if you're gonna
make an embedded solver well you might
have hard real-time execution limits
right so you might say I need I need to
know it and you know one millisecond
like period actually interesting well
okay I'll I'll skip over there actually
what's what's what people are actually
more concerned dependent practice is
actually extreme reliability and
robustness so you cannot have a
floating-point it's you know you can't
have a floating-point exception
obviously right
and you have to handle a poor quality
data that's not luck that's not outright
fraudulent data right if you allege that
a number a parameter is going to be
positive and you and you pass in the
number of minus ten you have violated
the caller has violated you know his
contract and I mean who knows what comes
out but we're talking about passing in
something that's like minus 1 t minus 5
or something which seems fair that's
poor and the other thing if they have to
have small footprint right this is for
real time applications right so you
can't be stopping for garbage collection
or allocating memory or anything like
this you know this is these are obvious
things okay so this is what you need for
one now you know if a general solver
works use it I mean if you have five
minutes to make a choice I mean not a
problem just I mean just use stuff that
works right now otherwise you can
develop some custom code by hand or you
can do it automatically via code
generation and when you do that you can
exploit various things that you would
know at solver development time but not
at at actual execution at solve time
right
so you'd separate what you know at at
problem at compile time from what you
know at actual solve time right so for
example traditional the date the
traditional data in a problem these are
the things this is precisely what you
are told when the solver is invoked
right the sparsity pattern however would
be known ahead of time so okay so what
happens if you build actually either way
here is instead of getting you could
easily expect a 10x speed up or 100x and
in fact what you typically get is things
like a thousand x essentially almost all
of that credit goes to the people who
make compilers right so the back end of
compilers because when you if you give
then
code that is nearly branch free they
have a they go nuts and they have a lot
of fun and the next thing you know they
reorder all the operations and the next
thing you know that's fast so okay so
the difference would be something like
CV X would be a parser solver so you
take a problem instance it would compile
it into a cone program solve the cone
program and that would give you X star
right this would be like this you would
describe a problem family the generator
would generate source code maybe see no
definitely see then you'd compile that
with all the flat all the flags on so
that all your friends and who do the
backend of compilers can show off and
you end up later somewhat later with a
you end up with a solver that's now a
custom solver that maps problems to
solutions actually so that's the that's
the idea and then this would this would
be a thousand times faster than that
would be the rough idea okay so this is
possible actually we've made like two or
three now other people have made a
couple but CVX gen is a very simple one
and this is like out of date but it's
just to show you that it's possible and
the idea is it takes a description of a
problem in a high-level language
done with domain-specific language then
it emits an emits flat C source actually
library free source that is then
compiled into a custom solver for that
specific problem right so and the input
might look like this this would be a
support vector machine I mean it doesn't
matter but so you would that this would
be the source input that is compiled
then into a flat C source which you then
compile you turn on all the optimization
flags
that's optimization at the compiler and
then you get a solver and so these are
out of date but it doesn't really matter
because the the point is that you get
things like like this and that and the
main thing actually is just that these
are all did these can be much faster now
and it doesn't really matter too much
yeah
you have to found the dimensions that
constant no in this case it for this
particular one you do yeah although if
you can that's fantastic right because
then we then we omit basically I mean
it's code that's like extremely explicit
yeah so some people have done where some
people have claimed to do that I'm a
little skeptical so FPGA stuff works
fine now so that that works so you can
compile directly into FPGAs and people
are at least I know a few instances
where people claim to do that that's
another that's a lot but actually
they're mostly it turns out it doesn't
speed up that much the power goes way
down that's what people care about
so yeah so in fact for some of those
it's slower but the number of joules is
a whole lot less yeah yeah so that's
yeah ok so actually the only thing about
that there the only note about this is
is to go back I mean none of these
details matter these are all off by
factors of 5 now it doesn't matter the
main point though is this which I think
I mean a high-level point is just this
you can solve a quite sophisticated
convex optimization problem in things
like 50 microseconds and the
implications of this are not I I don't
think have diffused widely enough right
so some people in control are aware of
this and using it others are hoping it
will just go away it's not going to
right but you could do this in a lot of
other areas as well so ok ok so I'm just
gonna wrap up so I mean they I mean so
these problems come up in a lot of
applications you can solve them
effectively so you know medium scale
problems and if you have seconds or more
or whatever it is to make a decision you
just you can just do that that's not a
problem we can solve small problems at
microsecond millisecond timescales the
other thing is you know high-level
language support makes a lot of this
stuff easy and you can actually do stuff
like the code generation stuff is only
going to get a lot better and there'll
be a lot more of it and stuff like that
so and it's actually gonna be
interesting because I think let me just
go to what the what I believe are some
of the big picture
shoes here right so it's actually kind
of interesting things like control let's
take let's just take one signal
processing even like control of networks
is another one I mean a lot of these
things were developed when computation
was expensive and slow right so I mean
even for example the the you know the
order of magnitude ten by ten by matrix
multiplication that you might do in a
modern controller now was considered
absolutely radical in like 1966 or
something like that right because people
were using PID control and all that kind
of stuff so so this is this is the the
existing the existing situation right
but now you can solve in the same amount
of time and by the way with the same
reliability I should add right so that
that's actually critical unless so
that's it would be the other main come
you know that'd be the other thing
people would say they would say no I'll
take a matrix multiply because I know
it's always going to work or something
like that that make I'm on there there
they got a good point there but you can
make these things extremely reliable so
the interesting thing is you go back and
now you rethink a lot of things and the
question is what could you by the way
the answer in some cases might be you
wouldn't do anything different right
that's entirely possible but my
suspicion is in a lot of cases you would
do things differently if you knew now
that you could do much you could
actually solve a full QP or something
like that in the time it takes you to do
your matrix operations or something like
that so okay so that's actually it I put
us back on on time but maybe we'll have
a few questions yeah no that's true in a
lot of areas where it turns out I mean
like in things like when you use this in
robotics and stuff like that it turns
out the that some other what happens is
the optimization when you profile it
goes from like you know 99 percent down
to like - at which point is just zero
right so for example in robotics
actually just linearizing the dynamics
around the current point you gonna be
doing a lot of like signs and
signs and they'll have lookup but that's
gonna dominate so the optimization just
goes away
so that's disappointing in your cases
disappoint I mean what can you do right
yeah to me see missing features great
sometimes you need to manually with
something so usually innovative system
we just get more points or viable over
time so don't want to solve a simple
scratch just to update another viable
wonders computers and Amazon Cloud we
won't use and this to do this is living
in distributed right yeah no you there
was there was a third one you said what
you mentioned brought up warm starting
right yeah yeah so warm starting is when
you I mean if you are doing a real-time
thing typically if you're doing control
you just solved some problem which is
essentially a plan of action over the
next 30 steps could be 30 milliseconds
right then you execute the first one
then you move forward a millisecond then
you do the same thing again right so
obviously you could start you have a
pretty good estimate of what what what
you would be doing because it's your
previous plan shifted one millisecond
okay so this for example these things
don't use that there are other methods
that do but these don't know so
streaming is handled in control and in a
lot of signal processing is handled in a
very ad hoc way that works just
perfectly and you just take a horizon
and that's that's the end of that right
so for example for streaming if you're
doing if you I'm estimating a parameter
and streaming I simply look at the last
hundred hundred as a parameter I look at
last hundred samples I that's where I'm
allowed to revise my history I solve a
convex problem to estimate what happened
over the last hundred samples but at
outside that hundred long memory window
the decisions made passed there are
locked down so that is fixed this work
that's streaming it works just fine it
works fine I mean depending on
okay okay well maybe you didn't do it
right but is what they're yes sir I mean
there are I know specific instances
where there are guarantees that this
will work there are because a lot of
well some non-convex optimization is
based as specific things like global
optimization are based on solving a
sequence of convex optimization problems
and so if you can make if you if you
have real time stuff that speeds things
up a thousand necks you can actually do
like small integer programs and things
like that so there are there are some
implications for that actually I'm glad
you asked that question because I should
I should tell you that I was I I
actually was someone who did like
hardcore circuit design who kind of set
me straight on a lot of these things
right so I showed some optimization why
I said that's the that's the global
solution that's the whole point
and the guy look at me I said no no you
have no idea what you're talking about
that's not the globulin I said well
actually it is as it happens he said
well how could you know and I said well
it has to do with the mathematical
properties of these the functions in
blah blah blah I said I know it says it
sounds like a ridiculous assertion but
it's this act of the glop and he said no
you could use a different circuit
topology and I was like you're right
it's the solution for the second apology
and he said now I'll tell you why this
is good you said had forget all your
global stuff just go put that take that
back to your university or whatever you
know he said I'll tell you why he said
this is good because it's reliable and
it starts from nothing you said you
don't have to start from a good guess
and then we give you a refined thing it
starts from zero and it always works and
I thought about for all and I realized
of course he was right so anyway but
which actually fits in well with
real-time decision making because here's
what you really want a real-time
decision making is you don't want you
want something that is unbelievably
reliable and let's leave it that way
that's what you need so yeah
for what is the bottom there for a lot
of problems is it the conversation time
the memories and the Mercury's that
really to you or what do you mean by a
large problem
those are nuts desert those are not
large that's small that's anything you
can that that you can do on a single
thread on a single it's that's that's
small so the limits are here would be
the limits one is how much can you stick
on a GPU that's one limit and that is
data just data size so GPU is one chunk
another is how much can you fit on
common memory so if I can I can get
things to 100 gigabytes of data and I
can have 64 cores or something that's
another threshold and then beyond that
you would get to you know but bigger
things and then I think beyond that I
would call it large scale so and there's
different methods for all these things
say for some part system problems I
guess the the problem typically are your
condition so there seems to be numerical
issues passing math have a 50,000 you
know less and less I mean for first
order methods yes the answer of course
there is right then you have
preconditioning to improve that or
something but actually for the things I
was talking about here I mean these are
just this is just for small and
medium-sized things you could use into
your point stuff and then there's it's
like two orders of magnitude less of an
issue
okay so move thanks people again